السلام عليكم والى العناوين
بعد سته ايام من فيضانات شرق ليبيا فرق
الاغاثه تكثف البحث عن المفقودين وتواصل
انتشال جثث الضحايا تحذيرات من تلوث
المياه والامم المتحده تقول ان الحجم
الحقيقي للكارثه لا يزال مجهولا والجزيره
ترصد الوضع من داخل دارنا وتواكب عمليات
البحث واللغاثه
اسبوعنا على زلزال الحوز في المغرب عمليات
البحث عن ناجين وانتشار جثمين الضحايا
تتواصل وسلطات تكثف جهود الاغاثه واياء
المتضررين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ونبدا من تداعيات السيول في
ليبيا
كثره خطر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
تواصلوا فرق الانقاذ المحليه والاجنبيه في
مدينه درنه وباقي المناطق المتضرره من
الاعصار والفيضانات في ليبيا تواصل جهودها
في البحث عن مفقودين واخراج احياء من وسط
الركام رغم صعوبه التحرك في شوارع مدينه
درنه وقد اعلن رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
عبد الحميد الدبيبه ان فرق البحث دفنت
اكثر من 2500 جثه انتشلتهم من درنه ومع
تصاعد اعداد القتلى والمفقودين ارتفعت
وتيره المناشدات من داخل درنه والمناطق
الاخرى طلبا لمزيد من الاليات والمعدات
وفرق الانقاذ والخدمات
معنى الان من درنا مراسلنا محمد البقالي
ومعنا ايضا من طرابلس مراسلنا احمد خليفه
نبدا
بالبقاله في درنه اليك محمد
[موسيقى]
عن واقع هذه المدينه المنسوبه وعندما
نتحدث عن المدينه المنكوة
لان النبي حدث في هذه المدينه هو غير
مسبوقه في تاريخها ربما في تاريخ المنطقه
الحديث الذي حدث هو ان فيضان تحول الى ما
يشبه السلطان وكانت اثاره المدمره تشبه
اثار واثار الزلزال في نفس الوقت لانه
عندما تزوجنا اليوم في المناطق المتضرره
شاهدنا المهدمه بشكل كامل شاهدنا الطيارات
التي حلقت بها الشهور على مسافه كيلومترات
وشاهدنا الشاطئ الذي انتفعت صخوره من
مكانها ويمكن ان اتصور حجم حجم الطوفان
الذي يفعل هذا الفعل وعليه يمكن ان نقول
ان الماكينه الحقيقه عاشت ما لم تعيش في
حياتها من قبل لا حديثا ولا ربما مقدما
لانه لم يرد لم يرد ما يمكن ان المدينه
هكذا هذا في التاريخ القديم طبعا هذا على
مستوى الصوره ولكن ليس من راى كما سمع
ثم فيما
يتعلقت لا عندما يتحدث الحديث الان عن
داخل 2500 فقط والذين اكثر
في عباده اكثر الان
المدينه في الحقيقه يمكن ان نقول انها
الان من هؤلاء الكارثه
وتسترجع انفاسها لتتساءل ما هذا الذي حدث
ولكن السؤال الكبير الذي يطرح الان هو كيف
يمكن تجنب ما لم يحدث بعد وما لم يحدث بعد
ايضا
لا قدر الله اذا حدث سيكون كارثيا بكل
المقاييس وهو الامر المتعلق بالوضع الصحي
في المدينه ذلك اين الاف الجثث ما زالت
تحت الانصار
والاتف بها البحر كل يوم
اذا
البحر
بشكل سريع وهناك تشتغل على هذا الامر وعلى
مدار الساعه ولكن المشكله الحقيقيه هي في
الجثث التي توجد تحت الالقاب هذه التي لم
يتم الوصول اليها بعد وفي الحقيقه هناك
صعوبات في الوصول اليها بالنظر الى اولا
الكلاب المساحه الكبيره التي تم تدميرها
يجهل
الاحاطه لكل هذه المساحه يتطلب امتنان
كبيره
واسرار عددهم كبير وخبره طويله وهذه
الامور كلها لا تتوفر الان هو
اما علاوه على حجم الكائن الكبير هناك
ايضا فرق الانقاذ برغم انها قد جاءت من
عدد كبير من الدول ولكنها تبدو غير قادره
على الوفاء الثريه بمتطلبات المرحله
بالنظر الى عددها بالنظر الى حجمها
وبالنظر ايضا الى حجم الكارثه وبالتالي ان
اقول
من البدايه ربما
في الايام هذا الناس
وبين
واخبار طيبه عن انقاذ هنا وهناك اليوم على
سبيل المثال تم الاعلان عن انقاذ شبان
كانوا قد حوصروا في احدى المهارات
وهناك من بقي في بيته محاصرا حاصره السيود
ولم يتم الوصول اليه في اخر لحظه وثم
انقاذين والامل باقي ولكنه في الحقيقه
امنوا متضائل ومتراجع بالنظر الى انه بعد
سته ايام
مثل هذه فان امكانيه
تصبح ضعيفه وايجاد واحياء
الحديمه الاحتمالات الضعيفه لذلك هناك
التركيز الان على تجنب هذه الك التي يمكن
ان تحدث الكارثه الصحيه خاصه وان هناك
تحذيرات من مساله المياه المياه التي بدات
تحليلات من انها اصبحت غير صالحه للشرب في
المدينه الج
ثه تداخليها المياه بسبب هذا الاعصار الذي
قلت انه يشمل في اثاره
في الانفاته ثم هناك اشكالات تبقى تتعلق
بمخاوف من انتفاخ بعض الامراض التي تنتشر
في مثل هذه الظروف وبالتالي الجهود كلها
مصدق على هذا الامر الان الذي اصبح يحتمل
اولويه خضراء الى جانب انقاذ من يكون من
قد يكونون على قيد الحياه ودفن الجثث التي
توجد تحت الركاب ثم هناك اولويه اخرى ايضا
تفرض نفسها وتتعلق بالتعامل مع النازحين
مع الذين فقدوا
زيارهم نتحدث عن احياء بكاملها محمد نورت
بمعنى هناك من شبه هذا الامر قال لي تامل
مدينه بقنبله نوويه والحقيقه انه لم يجانب
الصواب بشكل من الاشكال اللي انت عندما
تنظر الى المنطقه
المنطقه الافضل في المدينه بحضنه البحريه
وترى كيف ان الدور
احياء عندما اقول بشكل كامل بين العمره
ليس فيه اي مبالغه لغويه بل هو الحقيقه
التي يمكن ان يشاهدها كل من وصل الى هناك
30,000 تقريبا الان
انتشروا او لم وجدوا انفسهم بدون بيوت في
حسن ربما انها المجتمع الليبي هو مجتمع
متكافل ومتاز وهذا ربما يخفف كثيرا من هذا
العلم لان الجزء الاكبر من هؤلاء توجه الى
فرائنا اهله وربما اقربائه في مدن اخرى
كبيره اخرى وسنشاهد ربما الاف من الذين في
الشارع هذا الامر لم نشاهده
هذه
الروابليه والعائليه القويه في مجتمع مثل
المجتمع شكرا المدارس ومن يعيشون في بعض
المؤسسات ويواجه الصعوبات وهؤلاء ايضا
معهم كبيرا محمد الكثير مما في هذه
الماسات لانها ماساه غير مسم شكرا لك يا
محمد البقالي من درنا ماذا بالنسبه
لطرابلس وكيف تواكب ما يجري احمد خليفه
بالنسبه
لمحمد
انتهى المؤتمر الصحفي للفريق الحكومي
للطوارئ وهو فريق تابع لحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه تحدث بشكل عام عن هذه الازمه لكن
ابرز ما ورد في هذا المؤتمر هو الاعلان ان
وزاره الصحه حصلت الاضرار الماديه في بندي
المعدات والمستلزمات الطبيه في المناطق
المتضرره حصلتها بقيمه قرابه 20 مليون
دولار
ايضا نولدنا في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي ان
المساعدات الدوليه والمساعدات الاقليميه
جاءت على متن اكثر من 30 طائره حتى الان
ووصلت من سته عشره دوله ومن ضمن هذه
المساعدات ترقب بوصول سفينه تركيه تصل يوم
غد الى ميناء طبرق غرب
غرب مدينه درنه ايضا وفي سياق الاجراءات
الحكوميه
لمعالجه ما يحدث في درنه اعلنت وزاره
العدل هنا من مركزها الرئيسي بالعاصمه
طرابلس اعلنت لاهالي المفقودين حددت لهم
مقرات معينه او مواقع معينه في مدينه درنه
وطالبتهم بالذهاب اليها واعطاء عينات من
حمضهم النووي لمقارنه الحمض النووي
للاهالي بالحمض النووي للجثث التي يعثر
عليها بين حين واخر ايضا جهاز الاسكان
والمرافق بمنطقه الجبل الاخضر اعلن وعبر
مركزه الرئيسي هنا في طرابلس محمد
اعلن ان قيمه ان
اكثر من 5000 تحديدا شقه وعقار وبيت اكثر
من 5000 دمرت جراء السيول والفيضانات وقال
ان ذلك وافق تقرير مبدئي ايضا هذا الجهاز
اعلن ان طول الطرق التي اتضررت في مدينه
درنه تقدر ب 35 كيلو مترا وان امدادات
المياه التي دمرت بفعل هذه السيول تقدر
باكثر من 20 كيلو متر
ايضا في سياق اخر اعلن مركز الطب والطوارئ
لديه فرق عامله في مدينه درنه تعمل على
معالجه الروفات والتعامل مع رفات الضحايا
وايضا انتشال الجثث واقامه المستشفيات
الميدانيه
وتشغيل المستشفيات اعلن مركز الطب
والطوارئ ان فريقه في مدينه درنه وفي
مدينه سوسه ايضا شرط مدينه ادرنه اتفقت مع
الاطقم الطبيه في مستشفى الوحده التعليميه
بمدينه دردا وفي مستشفى سوسه على تشغيل
هذين المستشفيين علما ان هدينا المستشفيين
يعانيان منذ فتره
تراجعا في الامكانيات ايضا في سياق متصل
محمد اعلنت شركه الخدمات العامه ان الفرق
التابعه لها في مدينه درنه وهي فرق
الانقاذ وانتشال
الثواب معالجه اثار الطوفان او اثار
السيول في مدينه درنه اعلن انها ان هذه
الفرق انتشرت اكثر من 25 جثه من مناطق
متفرقه ضربها السيول او ضربتها السيول في
وقت سابق وقال ان الاليات التابعه له
تمكنت من فتح مسارات في مدينه درنه هذه
المسارات ستسهل عمليه انتقال الفرق الفنيه
التي تعالج الاوضاع العامه في مدينه درنه
وايضا فرق الانقاذ وهذه المسارات في شوارع
يمكن ان يسهل هذا الامر الدخول للبيوت
وانتشال الجثث اما من داخل البيوت او
انقاذ العالقين داخل البيوت وبالمناسبه
محمد منذ يومين تحديدا الاخبار لا تتوقف
عن انه تم العثور على احياء في مدينه درنه
وجدوا عالقين بين الركام وتحت ركام البيوت
ومن هؤلاء العالقين نساء واطفال
ايضا وفي سياق الاحصائيات التي تعلن بين
حين واخر عن اعداد الضحايا في مدينه ادرنه
اعلنا اليوم رئيس الحكومه عبد الحميد
الدبيبه على منصاته الرسميه ان الفرق
التابعه للحكومه في مدينه درنه دفنت اكثر
من 2500 جثه حتى الان وقال ان الحكومه
لديها فرق فنيه تعمل هناك على انتشال
الجثث
ومعالجه الرفاه مع ذلك محمد الاوضاع
الانسانيه بشكل عام كما ذكر الزميلان محمد
البقالي وتامر الصمادي في وقت سابق
الاوضاع الانسانيه متراجعه بشكل كبير في
مدينه درنه جراء هذه السيول والفيضانات
وهذا التراجع كانت له اصداءه هنا في
العاصمه طرابلس وتمثلت في حملات الدعم
والمساعده وتجميع التبرعات
وهذا شيء لم يتوقف منذ اسبوع في كل مكان
تقريبا في كل حي في العاصمه طرابلس توجد
نقاط لتجميع هذه التبرعات شكرا لك يا احمد
خليفه من طرابلس
هذا وقد حصلت الشبكه الجزيره على مشاهد
حصريه تظهر انتشال جثث لضحايا الفيضانات
من البحر في مدينه درنه وتظهر المشاهد جثه
هدفها البحر الى شاطئ المدينه وبدا فرق
الانقاذ عمليه انتشارهم هذا وتتواصل جهود
البحث من قبل فرق انقاذ الليبيه واجنبيه
املا في العثور على جثث ضحايا قذفت بهم
السيول الى البحر قباله شواطئ دنه
وقال نائب رئيس المجلس المحلي في مدينه
درنه احمد مد ورد للجزيره ان هناك توقعات
بامكانيه اخلاء المدينه بشكل كلي او جزئي
تحسبا لانتشار الاوبئه نتيجه الجثث التي
بدات في التحلل تحت الانقاذ وتوقع مدوارد
اخلاء حي الجبليه وحي المغار وما تبقى من
سكان وسط المدينه التي تعرضت للدمار مضيفا
ان هناك دراسه تجري لتقييم الوضع مؤكدا
نزوح اعداد كبيره من سكان الاحياء
المنكوبه
ينضموا الينا الان من طرابلس معاذ
الزرقاني مدير الاعلام بالهلال الاحمر
الليبي في طرابلس اهلا وسهلا بك ما
تقييمكم في الهلال للاوضاع الانسانيه الان
في درنا اهلا وسهلا بك استاذي الكريم في
مدينه درنه الاوضاع الانسانيه كانت في
الايامات الاولى الاوضاع الانسانيه اصعب
من الوقت الحالي للوقت الحالي لا زال
الفرق الانقاذ وقوافل الانسانيه الاغاثيه
في توافد ملحوظ داخل مدينه درنه ولا زال
فرق الهلال الاحمر على هبه استعداد لانقاذ
المتضررين ومساعده الاشخاص المحتاجين الى
الماوى والغذاء والمستلزمات الطبيه ماذا
عن الامكانات المتاحه
لديكم الان
كرر السؤال الامكانات التي لديكم الان هل
هي كافيه
الامكانيات المتاحه لدينا هنا طبعا طرابلس
فاتحين باب التبرع بخصوص التبرعات
المواد الاغاثيه الطبيه
في تجاوب كبير من قبل المواطنين ومن قبل
المنظمات المجتمع المدني في مساعدتنا في
توفير اغلب المستلزمات
لمدينه دارنا طبعا هناك
ارساليات اجنبيه تصل الان ما مدى التنسيق
بينكم وبينها طبعا في منطقه شرقيه تم
تشكيل غرفه مركزيه خاصه باستقبال فرق
الانقاذ وجميع المساعدات الفرقه الغرفه
المركزيه هي المسؤوله على توزيع المهام
بين المنظمات المجتمع المدني بالاضافه الى
الفرق لانقاذ التابعه للحكومه الليبيه ما
مدى رضاكم على
مساعيكم ومساعي الاخرين في محاوله احتواء
الوضع الانساني هناك
لا واضح واضح انه لا يسمعني شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد الزرقاني
هذا وقد قال مدير مركز مكافحه الامراض
للجزيره حيدر السائح ان المياه في مدينه
دره درنه ملوثه وغير صالحه للشرب مع توقف
كامل لمحطاته تحليه المياه واضاف انه يجب
اعلانه حاله الطوارئ لمده سنه في كافه
المدن المنكوبه
في الاثناء اعلن المركز الوطني لمكافحه
الامراض في ليبيا عن تسجيل 55 حاله تسمم
بين الاطفال جراء تلوث المياه في درنه
وتوقع حيدر السائح رئيس المركز في حديث
لوسائل الاعلام الليبيه ارتفاع حالات
التسمم في درنا جراء النظام الصحي
المتهالك
هذا وتتصاعد وتحذيرات من حدوث كارثه صحيه
وبيئيه في المناطق المنكوبه جراء الاعصار
وعلى وجه الخصوص مدينه درنه اذ يحذر خبراء
البيئه من انتشار الامراض المعديه
والاوبئه نتيجه التلوث مياه الشرب في
المدينه
دارنا المنكوبه وجه اخر يتكشف عن مدينه
منهكه لم تكن السيول سوى ضربه قاسمه لها
تتعمق الماساه الانسانيه في درنا بحديث
خبراء البيئه عن هواجس من تفشي الاوبئه
والامراض المعديه بسبب تدمير شبكات الصرف
الصحي والنفايات التي تحملها مياه السيول
يتحدث تقرير للامم المتحده عن خطر انتشار
امراض مثل السل والحصبه والانفلونزا في
المناطق المنكوبه شرقيه ليبيا فالنفايات
التي تحملها مياه السيول تحتوي مواد ضاره
ما سيؤدي الى تلوث مياه الشرب والابار
وبالتالي نشر الامراض والاوبئه المركز
الوطني لمكافحه الامراض في ليبيا اعلن
تسجيل 55 حاله تسمم بين الاطفال جراء تلوث
المياه في دارنا حذر المركز من ارتفاع
حالات التسمم فالنظام الصحي هناك متهالك
ويطالب باخلاء كامل المدينه نحو 300 الف
انسان كانوا يعيشون في درنه قبل الكارثه
لسنوات عان هؤلاء من تهاون منظومه الصحيه
فدرنا ثالث اكبر مدينه في الشرق الليبي
لكنها تضم ثلاثه مرافق صحيه حكوميه فقط هي
مستشفى الوحده التعليميه الجامعي ومستشفى
الهريش وهو مجمع عيادات حكومي ومستوصف
شيحه عام 2019 خرج مستشفى الهريش عن
الخدمه وظل متوقفا عن العمل حتى يومنا هذا
اما مستشفى الوحده وهو على الرغم من انه
المستشفى المركزي والاكبر في درنه فقد كان
يعمل قبل الكارثه بعشره في المئه فقط من
طاقته ليبقى مستوصف شيحه المرفق الصحي
الحكوميه الوحيد الذي لم يتوقف عن العمل
ولكنه ذو طاقه محدوده وامكانيات متواضعه
جدا عانى افتقارا في الكوادر الطبيه اذ لم
يتجاوز عدد الاطباء فيها الثمانيه
بالاضافه الى سبعه مساعدين ومن صور حول
الكارثه شكوى هل الضحايا من شح الاكياس
الخاصه بالجثث بل ان ثلاجات الموتى رغم
تكدس الجهد داخلها متوقفه عن العمل
لانقطاع الكهرباء عن المدينه وقد اضطرت
فرق الطوارئ في درنا الى نقل الجثث على
متن شاحنات الى مستشفى طبرق الى حين
التعرف عليها ودفنها
[موسيقى]
ومعنى عبر الهاتف من درنا ايناس المزيني
الناشطه المدنيه والمتطوعه اهلا وسهلا بك
دور المتطوعين حاليا في درنا
للاسف سيده ام زينه لم تعد معنا عبر
الهاتف نواصل اذا تغطيه الحدث الليبي فقد
قال احمد المسماري المتحدث باسم الجيش في
بنغازي ان الاعصار الذي ضرب منطقه الجبل
الاخضر هو الاسوا الذي تشهده ليبيا وانه
جرف كل شيء امامه مشيرا الى تاثر اكثر من
مليون شخص بالسيول
يعني نتحدث من ناحيه السكان على حوالي
اكثر من مليون و 200 الف نسمه يقبلون في
هذه المناطق وهذه المنطقه بالسكان هذه
المنطقه فيها خمس مدن رئيسيه وهي مدينه
المرج بعد ذلك مدينه البيضه بعد ذلك شحات
سوسه القبه هذه المنطقه
هذا الوصف السكاني والوصف الخريطه
الطبيعيه لهذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه ضربت
بالكامل هذا الاحصار عندما دخل من من
اتجاه الغرب الى الشرق يقوم بمسح كل شيء
امامنا
عوده الى ايناس الناشطه المدنيه والمتطوعه
كنت سالتك سيده مزيني عن دور المتطوعين
فيما يجري الان في درنا
مرحبا
فرقه فرق الانقاذ تواصل بحثها وكذلك
المتطوعين عن العالقين تحت الانقاذ تم
استخراج الان امراه كانت عالقه تحت
الانقاذ من منذ اكثر من 120 ساعه
تم العثور ايضا على مئات الجثث في احد
الاوديه المجاوره لمدينه درنا لا يزال
المتطوعون يقومون بافضل المجهودات
للمساعده كذلك تم ربط النسخ الشرقي
والغربي من المدينه مجددا عن طريق الالات
الثقيله التي قامت بازاله الركام لتوصيل
والمحاوله خلقه وصل مجددا بين جزء الشرقي
والغربي من المدينه وكذلك في توصيل
المساعدات والمؤن الى الناجين واسر
المنتظر هل هناك اطار معين ينشط فيه
المتطوعون حتى لا يكون العمل فوضويا
المتطوعون يقومون بمجهود رائع حقا هناك
فرق مختصه فقط بتوفير الادويه فرق بتوفير
الاغاثه والمؤن فرق
بها عناصر نسائيه
لتوفيل الملابس
والمستلزمات النسائيه لا يزال
الاليه التوزيع قليلا بطيئه كما قلنا من
قبل كانت المدينه
مقسومه الى نصفين الى نصف شرقي وغربي مما
يصعد على المتطوعين التنقل بسهوله ولكن
الان واليوم نرى مجهودات جبار جدا
هل وصل متطوعون من محافظات اخرى
[موسيقى]
ضواحي المدينه نعم ما مدى تنسيق القائم
بين المتطوعين والجهات الرسميه هناك
التنسيق بشكل مباشر حتى الاغاثات لا تصل
الا عن طريق التنسيق من كل مدن ليبيا
المتطوعون وكذلك من يدخل الى المدينه تتم
متابعتهم بشكل شخصي حتى هناك تواصل مباشر
جدا بين بين الجميع
اشرت الى وجود متطوعات وهذا ربما تطور مهم
في المجتمع الليبي ان يحدث هذا بشكل بارز
وفعال
وايضا متبرعات ومتطوعات
لتسهيل توصيل الاغاسات كذلك يتم التواصل
عن طريق مجموعات على الانترنت لتسهيل
وتيسير توصيل بين بين المتطوعات من خارج
المدينه ودخلها شكرا لك ايناس المزيني كنت
معنا من درنه ناشطه المدنيه والمتطوعه
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان الوضع
في شمال شرق ليبيا مقلق للغايه وقال
كريستيانونال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الالمانيه في معرض رده على سؤال للجزيره
ان طائرات من سلاح الجو الالماني وصلت الى
مدينه بنغازي محمله بمساعدات للمتضررين في
درنه مشيرا الى ان بلاده على تواصل مع من
وصفهم بالشركاء الدوليين ومنظمات الاغاثه
الدوليه والامم المتحده لبحث سبل تقديم
المزيد من تلك المساعدات
عندي الوضع في ليبيا وشمال شرقها مقلق
للغايه المشاهد الوارده من الموقع وعدد
الضحايا لم يتكشف بشكل كامل لهذه الكارثه
الا تدريجيا ربما لاحظتم انه مساء امس
وبفضل مساعده القوات الجويه وصلت امدادات
الاغاثه الاولى التي ارسلناها الى بنغازي
ويتم الان نقلها بسرعه الى المنطقه
المتضرره وبالطبع نحن على اتصال وثيق
للغايه مع شركائنا الدوليين ومنظمات
الاغاثه الدوليه والامم المتحده التي
لديها مكتب تنسيق مهم في الموقع لنرى كيف
يمكننا الان القيام بشيء اضافي وتقديم
المزيد من المساعده
وقال مسؤول المساعدات الانسانيه بالامم
المتحده
ان ليبيا بحاجه الى معدات للعثور على
الاشخاص المحاصرين في الوحل والمباني
المتضرره في درنه وشدد غرفت في مؤتمر
الصحفي على حاجه المدينه الى رعايه صحيه
عاجله لمنع تفشي الكوليرا بين الناجين
هناك حاجه الى معدات للعثور على الاشخاص
المحاصرين في الوحي والمباني المتضرره في
درنا وضواحيها بعد السيول والفيضانات التي
اودت بحياه الالاف ونحتاج ايضا الى تلك
المجالات ذات الاولويه وهي الماوى والغذاء
والرعايه الطبيه الاوليه بسبب القلق من
الكوليرا والقلق من نقص المياه النظيفه
الامر الذي يشكل تهديدا كبيرا لحياه
الاطفال
ينضم الينا من تونس احمد بيرما المستشار
الاعلامي للشرق الاوسط في المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين اهلا وسهلا بك ما هي مساهمتكم
حاليا في
عمليات التي تجري في درنه
مساء الخير استاذ محمد حاليا فرقنا على
مشارف دارنا
حاليا فرقه فريقنا على مشارفنا خرجنا من
بنغازي لدينا فريق حوالي البيت عامل
انساني
نتوجه الى دارنا لتقديم مساعدات مختلفه
عينيه منها البطانيات او مساعدات اغطيه او
حتى
مساعدات بسيطه معدات مطبخ بسيطه لحتى
الناس تقدر
تتاقلم مع الوضع هذا الوضع طبعا مساعدات
اللي عم تتقدم اللي هي بالمرحله الثانيه
من بعد عمليه الانقاذ راح تكون انيه وهذا
الشيء بيعني انه على المدى الطويل لازم
يكون في مساعدات بشكل مختلف لكن حاليا في
ناس كتير عم تفضي
عم تمضي ليالي
وايام في في العراء في ناس عم تقعد مع
اشخاص مقربين الى عم يسبب اقتزاز
بالملاجئ او بالمقاول اللي عم تكون موجوده
بنفس الوقت عم نكون احنا موجودين
انفتحت في بنغازي حاولت 18 مدرسه لحكون
متواجدين بالعديد من المناطق لحتى نساعد
الناس تتاقلم مع الوضع والاخص مع موجات
النزوح اللي عم نشوفها واللي بنتوقع انه
راح نشوفها بشكل متزايد في الايام المقبل
ما يجري في درن ربما وضع غير مسبوق هل
تشعرون بذلك كتحدي لوجستي فيما تقومون به
حاليا
بالتاكيد على تحذيراتنا كانت يعني للاسف
ما كان عم بيتم الاصغاء كلها السنين من
بعد اذا بدك ما خفت وتيره الصراع في في
ليبيا للاسف
اداره
اداره المجتمع الدولي لظاهري خلينا نقول
تمويليا للاسف هاي كارثه يعني كان جزء
منها
يعني جزء من هالكارسه هو نتيجه عدم مساعده
ليبيا للنهوض مره ثانيه لمساعده المجتمع
الليبي على اعاده بناء الخدمات الحيويه
هذا الشيء بالتاكيد في بلد ليبيا بلدان
اخرى كوارث مشابهه بيتفاقم للاسف تاثير
هكذا كارثه يعني بالتاكيد هي اسوا نسبه
امطار او اثقل نسبه امطار شفناها على نسبه
امطار باربعين سنه ولكن بنفس الوقت البنيه
التحتيه لبلد بهشاشه البنيه التحتيه مثل
ليبيا للاسف لانه غاب التمويل عن سنه
اكبر ومتفاقي اشرت الى النازحين والى فتح
بعض المدارس لاواء هؤلاء اشار اكثر من ضيف
الى ان الطابع التضامني في المجتمع الليبي
كان كبيرا وبالتالي كثير من العائلات ذهبت
الى اقربائها هل هذا خفف نوعا ما من حجم
كارثه النزوح هناك
الموضوع انا لمسته من زملائي شخصيا يلي من
ثاني يوم
بيمروا الظروف الصعبه ولكن زملائنا في
الشرق ليبيا في التحديدا لمسنا اللي هي
رغبه في المساعده رغبتهم في المساعده
بالرغم النقص التمويل بالرغم من نقص
الموارد بالرغم من عدم جهوزيه الوضع
يعني حتى كان ما قبل التقييم كانت الناس
بدات فرديه من المجتمع الليبي كتير مشجعه
وحاليا حتى العمال الانسانيين لازم انوه
على هذا الشيء لانه في فكره انه العمل
الانساني
لا يقتصر على المحليين وهذا الشيء صحيح
ولكن بنفس الوقت المحليين الناس اللي هم
من السكان ليبيا حاليا عم بيقوموا من خلال
منظمات وعم بسمع كلمه لمقابلات مع متطوعين
حتى هل هل تعاضد اللي صار بالمجتمع يعني
عم بيكون بتخيل راح يكون له تاثير كثير
كبير على على مساعده الناس وشفنا الناس
اللي كانت
بتقدم المساعدات وبتمنى هذا الشيء يكمل
معه يعني
شفناه بالسنوات الاخيره كيف قادرين لديهم
المرونه على التعامل مع هذا الوضع ولكن
بالتاكيد بده المساعده مساعده من من
العالم كله يحط
ورا ورا الناس شكرا جزيلا لك احمد بينم
المستشار الاعلامي للشرق الاوسط في المجلس
النرويجي للاجئين كنت معنا من تونس
[موسيقى]
الان الى المغرب والمشهد بعد مرور اسبوع
على زلزل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد اسبوع من زلزال المغرب تتواصل عمليات
البحث عن ناجين وانتشالي جثمين الضحايا في
غضون ذلك تستمر عمليات فتح الطرق الجبليه
المؤديه الى القرى النائيه وسط مخاوف من
انهيارات صخريه جديده وكانت وزاره
الداخليه قد افادت بارتفاع عدد قتل
الزلزال الى
2946 والمصابين الى خمسه الاف وستمائه
واربعه وسبعين وكان السلطات المغربيه قد
اعلنت بدء تنفيذ المرحله الاولى من خطه
طارئه لانوئ لايواء متضرري الزلزال
للوقوف على المشهد عن قرب نذهب الان الى
المغرب وعثمان اي فرح وجوله مع مراسلينا
على الارض هناك اليك عثمان
شكرا محمد بالفعل اذا بدات هذه المرحله
الاولى من الاجراءات التي تم الاعلان عنها
بعد اجتماع العمل الذي عقده الملك محمد
السادس مرحله اولى وطبعا منذ البدايه بدا
العمل على جهود الانقاذ والمساعدات
ومحاوله انتشار العالقين وانتشال الجثث
ولكن ايضا بعد الاتفاق من هول الصدمه في
الايام الاولى لا شك لا يتوقف الامر فقط
على المساعدات ولكن التفكير في
استراتيجيات البناء كيف سيعاد بناء ما
تهدم كيف سيكون التلاميذ في مدارسهم متى
سيبداون اين سيبداون اليتامى كيف سوف يتم
التكفل بهم العدد الكبير من الاسر نتحدث
عن نحو 50,000 اسره متضرره حتى هذه اللحظه
وهذه الاسر يواكب حياتها مراسلون معنا
المختار العدلاوي من تحناوت في الحوز
ومعنى من مراكش عمر الحاج عمر سابدا بك
بالنسبه لاماكن الايواء هناك الخيم
البدائيه انجاز ان نقول بالجهود الذاتيه
وهناك الخيم التي وفرتها السلطات ولكن
يعني هناك انواع من
السكن الذي يتم توفيره في هذه المرحله
هذا صحيح هذا صحيح بلا شك عثمان ولكن
بدايه يجب ان نشير الى ان السلطات وحتى
المساعدات الاهليه التي تنطلق سواء بجهود
الفرديه او بجهود المنظمات منظمات المجتمع
المدني تركز على جهود الايواء للمتضررين
في
البلدات
والدوارات او الدولارات او الضياع كما
يصطلح عليها هنا الجهود تصل الى تلك
المناطق تباعا المناطق التي اليها طرق
سالكه ليس فيها خطر خاصه في الجنوب في
مركز الزلزال في الحوز اضافه الى مشهد
جديد بدنا نراه وهو خيم مختلفه عن الخيم
الصفراء الاولى التي تعد اسعافيه ان الصحه
القول خيم تمتاز بانها مقاومه اكثر لدرجه
الحراره البارده منها والمرتفعه اضافه الى
انها فيها عزل اكبر
وسط المحيط بهذه الخيمه هذا شاهدناه في
مناطق مختلفه في الحوز وفي مناطق قليله
نسبيا في الشيشاوه الاهم الان كما ذكرنا
هو الاسراع في جهود الانقاذ التي تحدثت
عنها عثمان
الحكومه هنا في المغرب وجهت بالاسراع في
عمليه بدء الايواء واحترام الظروف
والشروط الانسانيه كما وصفتها للمواطنين
من خلف هنا سيريكم الزميل المصور هذه
الخيام التي انشات بجهود فرديه كما ذكرت
الاولويه كلها حتى كما شاهد فيها الصوره
هناك اشخاص بدون خيام بعد دقائق ربما هذا
المنظر سيتغير عثمان الى درجات الحراره
تتسم بنوع من البروده والانخفاض في مراكش
ذلك ولكن مع هذا هناك اناس يقررون او
يريدون ان يبيتوا في هذه المناطق في خارج
بيوت التي بعض متضرر بشكل كبير ايضا قبل
قليل كان هناك جولات مكثفه لفرق الهلال
الاحمر المغربي والتي كانت تدور على هؤلاء
توقفنا الحديث معهم سالناهم عن جهودهم
قالوا اننا هنا لنقنع هؤلاء بالتوجه الى
المناطق
المنشات المغلقه التي اعدتها السلطات
لهؤلاء ولكنهم اشاروا ان الكثير منهم
لاسباب مختلفه يودون البقاء هنا حتى في
هذه الظروف الجويه الصعبه منهم من يخاف من
الزلزال منهم من له تحفظات اخرى لانها تلك
المناطق مقتظه جدا ولكن
السلطات سواء باجهزتها الهلال الاحمر
وايضا القوى المساعده وغيرها اضافه الى
منظفات منظمات المجتمع المدني حقيقه تبذل
قصار جهدها لاغاثه هؤلاء ولكن سلم
الاولويات او من ياتي في ترتيب الاوليات
الاولويات هم الموجودون في المناطق
المنكوبه وتحديدا في مركز الزلزال
نعم مازال الناس خارقين بطبيعه الحال وهم
يبيتون في العراء لاسباب متنوعه في
الحقيقه قد نتحدث عنها بعد قليل مع ضيفنا
ولكن اذهب الى الحوز المختار العملاوي الى
تحناوت والتحديد والمختار اليوم واليوم
الثامن كانت كان هناك يوم جمعه ولكن دون
صلاه جمعه في في تحناوت
نعم عثمان وقبل ذلك كانت هنا صلاه العشاء
في الباحه الخارجيه للمسجد دون الدخول الى
المسجد بالنظر الى وضعه هنا اليوم مرت
صلاه الجمعه بدون اداء صلاه الجمعه مره
اليوم حزينا عند الكثيرين في تحناوت هنا
في اسني في امليل في امزميز في اقليم
الحوز والاقاليم الاخرى التي ضربها
الزلزال في المعجم لم تقم صلاه الجمعه رغم
انه يوم الجمعه وللاشاره منذ جائحه كورونا
لم تتوقف صلاه الجمعه الا بفعل الزلزال
وعثمان صلاه الجمعه هنا في المغرب ليست
فقط يعني عباده دينيه بل هي خصوصا في
الدواوير القريبه وفي معظم المناطق
المغربيه هي طقس وعاده اجتماعيه فيها
يلتقي المغاربه وفيها يتزاورون وفيها
يتحدثون الى بعضهم البعض بعد صلاه الجمعه
كما انها ترتبط عند المغ
[موسيقى]
وتارودانت مرورا بتحناوت وامزميز تواصل
توافد القوافل قوافل للمحسنين المغاربه
للمغاربه المغتربين بالخارج وايضا كان
ملحوظا وجود منظمات دوليه وناشطين اجانب
يقدمون مختلف الخدمات الطبيه
ويقدمون مواد اساسيه كالاطعمه والافريشه
والادويه ويقومون ايضا بمعاينه المرضى نعم
وهذه سياره اسعاف الان في اشاره الى
استمرار شكرا
[موسيقى]
البحث وانقاذ اللاجئين في هذه المناطق
عثمان
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك المختار عبلاوي من
تحناوت في اقليم الحوز وعمر الحاج من
مراكش وهنا ينضم الي الخليل بولحسن وهو
رئيس اللجنه المكلفه بالشؤون الثقافيه
والاجتماعيه في مجلس جماعه مراكش اي
البلديه هنا في مراكش السيد خليل اهلا
وسهلا بك وانا اود ان اسالك بدايه عن جهود
المجلس او جهود البلديه في الايواء الى
اين وصلت بدايه اشكر جزيره مباشر على
الاستضافه يعني لابد اولا من تعزيات الاسر
الضحايا سواء داخل المغرب واكثر من فرصه
كذلك لتعزيه ضحايا فيضانات دارنا بليبيا
كما قلت لجمع المجلس جماعه مراكش منذ
الولاه الاولى والساعات الاولى من حدوث
الزلزال هرع الى التدخل من خلال اختصاصاته
وامكانياته حيث منذ ساعات الاولى انتقلت
السيده العمده رئيسه المجلس بل
المستشارين الى يعني الى الاماكن الاكثر
تضررا خاصه بالمدينه العتيقه تحديدا على
مستوى حي السلام الملقب قديما بحلم ملاح
وغيرها من الاحياء التي تضررت اكثر لتفقد
احوال الساكنه على اعتبار ان مزيج جماعه
مراكش يمثل يمثل ساكنه نعم فوريه كما فهمت
ولكن كما عدد الناس الذين تم اياهم وكم هم
كم هي الاسره التي فقدت منازله نعم بطبيعه
الحال مجلس نتحدث عن مراكش نعم في جماعه
مراكش بطبيعه الحال انخرط في هذه العمليه
من خلال التنسيق الافقي والعمودي مع طبيعه
الحال السلطات المحليه لتوفير واحد
المجموعه ديال مراكز الايواء سواء مراكز
الايواء المشتركه مع السلطات المحليه او
مراكز ايواء الخاصه بمجلس جماعه بمراكش في
اطار التنسيق كذلك وتنفيذا للتوجيهات
الساميه لجلاله الملك حيث تم احداث
نحن واعون على انه العدد كبير جدا من
الاسر المتضرره والضحايا خاصه الذين فقدوا
منازلهم بشكل يعني كبير اي المنازل التي
انهارت بشكل كبير او المنازل التي بها
تصدعات ولكن مراكز الايوائيه كثيره كما
قلت ليس مركز واحد عندنا المركز
واحد القاعه كبيره قاعه كبرى ديال الاعمال
الاجتماعيه متواجد بمقاطعه كما تعرف انه
بجماعه مراكش عندنا مجموعه من المقاطعات
وبالتالي واحد المجموعه ديال مراكز
الايواء بمجموعه من المقاطعات من بلاد
المركز هذا كذلك الذي واحد العدد كبير من
الساكنه المتضرره كذلك عندنا مركز بملعب
كبير
جدا ولكن يبدو ان هناك من لا يريد الذهاب
الى هذه المراكز نعم تعرف انه حول الفاجعه
والكارثه وله وقع نفسي على واحد العديد
ديال الناس وديال الاسر بالتالي هناك من
يخاف من يخاف ان ياوي الى الى البنايات
وان ياوي الى الخيام الكبرى ويفضل ان يعني
ان يبقى يعني في الحدائق العموميه
وبجانب الصور ولكن هادو كلهم راه تحت
العنايه والمراقبه ديال السلطه ويتم توفير
يعني
الطعام يتم توفير كل الوسائل الضروريه لهم
الوسائل الصحيه شكرا نتمنى لكم التوفيق
خليل ابو الحسن رئيس اللجنه المكلفه
بالشؤون الثقافيه والاجتماعيه في مجلس
جماعه مراكش اي البلديه اذا هذا هو الوضع
حاليا
محمد ولعله لفت نظرك ان السيد خليل كان
يتحدث عن المواكبه النفسيه كذلك وذلك امر
مهم للغايه لمن عاشوا هول هذه الصدمه
والفاجعه خاصه من الاطفال
شكرا لكم عثمان
يمر سكان القرى المتضرره من الزلزال في
اقليم تارودانت بالمغرب باوضاع صعبه بعد
زلزال الحوز الذي ضرب المنطقه الجمعه
الماضي ويامل سكان هذه القرى ان تسهم
سلطاته في رفع العزله عن قراهم والاسراع
في اعاده ترميم المدارس وتوفير فرص العمل
مكان الفاجعه
سركامي يبحث عبد الحفيظ عما تبقى من
وثائقه الشخصيه
لا اله الا الله ويتحسر على فقدان والده
الذي تعذر عليه انقاذه ليله الزلزال
شانه في ذلك شان مجموعه من الناجين
المجبرين على العمل في مناطق بعيده عن
قراهم
[تصفيق]
لا فرص عمل هنا يقول سكان المناطق
المنكوبه فزراعه لا تكفي لتامين الحياه
الكريمه لكنهم رغم ذلك
يتشبثون بالمكوث في قرن شيدها اجدادهم حتى
ان كان ذلك مرادفا لعزله تفرضها طرق وعره
يستنزف سلوك دروبها نصف ساعات النهار
تقريبا تنمشي اربعه مرات في النهار تنمشي
تنطلع ديال الطريق وتايخصني نرجع عاوتاني
الساعه ديال الطريق وتنمشي عده مرات في
النهار اربعه المرات خمسه مرات في النهار
ولان النوائب لا تاتي فرادى يخشى
المنكوبون ان يطول عدم التحاق اطفالهم
بالمدارس
فالمؤسسات التعليميه التي تؤوي اطفال
القرى القصيه لم تسلم بدورها من عنف
الزلزال
لذلك تحاول الجمعيات المحليه ايجاد حلول
مؤقته لاطفال لم يستسلموا لقسوه اوضاع ما
بعد الزلزال نحن كجمعيه لشباب
دوار نفكر حاليا واتصلنا بمجموعه من
الجمعيات الفعاله في مدن اخرى باش توفر
لنا الحاويات من اجل ترصيه مدارس مؤقته وي
منها مجموعه من الدوائر الاخرى لا يملك
ضحايا زلزال الحوز الا التاقلم مع واقع
جديد لا يقل قسوه عن واقعهم الذي كانوا
فيه لكنهم يخشون ان يتحول هذا الوضع
المؤقت الى وضع دائم وان يزيدهم عزله بعد
عزله ايمن الزبير الجزيره من قريه تيزنتاس
في شمال اقليم تارودانت
عوده الى تطورات كارثه الفيضانات في ليبيا
معنا من درنه مراسلنا تامر الصمادي نسال
تامر عن المؤتمر الصحفي للجنه الطوارئ
التابعه للحكومه المكلفه من مجلس النواب
في المستشفى الميداني بذرنا وقد تبعته
تامر
اما بالفعل محمد كانت هنالك تصريحات لافته
للنائب العام الذي قال بانه كلف 26
نائبا عاما بالتحقيق في مجريات ما جرى
والاهمال الذي وقع على حده وصفه وقال بان
التحقيق الابرز سوف يركز على انهيار
السدين في درنه
السبب وراء ذلك وقال بان هنالك دراسه في
عام 2002 اشارت الى ضروره اجراء صيانه
للسدين وقال بانه دفعت اموال لتلك الصيانه
وانه سوف يتم التحقيق في تلك الاموال والى
اين
ذهبت لكونها لم تذهب الى صيانه السدين
وقال بان هذه التحقيقات سوف تطال عددا من
المسؤولين الحاليين بالاضافه الى حكومات
متعاقبه
كما قال وكانت هنالك تصريحات لرئيس
الوزراء
الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان الليبي
بالاضافه الى وزير الصحه فيها حيث تحدثا
عن الوضع في الوضع الصحي في المدينه وقال
بان بانه سوف يتم العمل على عزل المناطق
الاكثر تضررا جراء العاصفه الاخيره وذلك
تحسبا لعدم انتشار الوباء في المناطق
الوباء المحتمل بطبيعه الحال في المناطق
الاقل تضررا لسيما ان الحديث
ركز بشكل كبير على المناطق التي لا زالت
تحتفظ بكثير من الجثث تحت الانقاض في
الحقيقه محمد الوضع في درنه هو وضع كارثي
بامتياز منذ الصباح
ونحن نتجول في عديد المناطق في عديد
الاحياء التي طالها هذا الاعصار
وهنالك فرق اغاثه تعمل على مدار الساعه
وحتى هذه اللحظه بحثا عن العالقين وبحثا
عن المفقودين كنا اعددنا تقريرا عن تطورات
الوضع هناك اتابعه معكم
سنشاهد التقرير لاحقا وايضا ستكون لنا
عوده لك تامر في سياق تغطيتنا المتواصله
شكرا لك تامر
في اخبار اخرى رحب جاك سليمان مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي بزياره وفد حوثي
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه داعيا جميع
الاطراف الى زياده تعزيز فوائد الهدنه في
اليمن
الى السعوديه هي خطوه كبيره تحدث لاول مره
منذ فتره طويله فهي تاتي في لحظه بعد مرور
18 شهرا من الهدنه التي وضعت حدا للعنف
الذي حل باليمن في السنوات الماضيه نحن
نحيي حكومه عمان على جهودها المتواصله في
هذا الاطار ونحن نعمل عن قرب مع الاطراف
اليمنيه والامم المتحده نحن نحيي القياده
السعوديه ايضا وهي تعمل على انهاء الصراع
في اليمن ونعتقد ان ذلك سيعود بالنفع على
الجميع
سلمت الكويت مذكره احتجاجا لسفير العراق
لديها على خلفيه حكم المحكمه العليا
الدستوريه في العراق والقاضي بعدم دستوريه
اتفاقيه تنظيم الملاحه البحريه بين
البلدين في خور عبد الله وقال بيان
للخارجيه الكويتيه ان مساعده وزير
الخارجيه سلم السفير العراقي مذكره
احتجاجا على ما ذكر في حي على ما ذكر عفوا
بحيث ياتي الحكم حول الاتفاقيه المبرمه
بين البلدين بشان تنظيم الملاحه البحريه
في خور عبد الله
سوداني ان سته اشخاص لقوا مصرعهم بسبب
سيول وامطار ضربت عده مناطق في ولايه نهر
النيل شمال البلاد قالت مصادر محليه
للجزيره ان مئات المنازل انهارت بسبب سيول
وامطار ضربت ثلاث بلدات بمحليه بربر في
ولايه نهر النيل شماليه السودان واكدت
المصادر ان اكثر من 350 منزلا انهارت بشكل
كامل في قريه السينما جنوبي بربر اضافه
الى انهيار بيوت اخرى لم يتم حصرها في كل
من قريتي السعديه والنبويه وزار والي
الولايه القرى المتضرره اليوم ودع
المنظمات الانسانيه لتقديم يد العون
للمتضررين
قالت مندوبه الولايات المتحده دائما لدى
الامم المتحده ليندا توماس غريفيلد ان
تهديد القاده العسكريين في السودان بانهاء
مهمه الامم المتحده في البلاد امر غير
مقبول واضافت غريفيلد في لقاء مع مجله
الامريكيه ان هذا التهديد مدان وعلى قاده
العسكر سحبه على الفور حسب تعبيرها
هذا التهديد غير مقبول على الاطلاق وعلينا
ان ندينهم عليه تقدم بعثه الامم المتحده
هناك الدعم للشعب السوداني وهذه البعثه
مهمه لضمان استمرارنا في دعم الشعب
السوداني والوقوف الى جانبه لذا فانني
احثهم على ان يسحبوا هذا التهديد وان
يبحثوا عن طريقه للعمل مع الامم المتحده
لفتح الممرات الانسانيه لكي تتمكن
المساعدات الانسانيه من المرور وان يمنحوا
التاشيرات للعاملين في المجال الانساني
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها
دمرت 17 طائره مسيره روسيه من طراز شاهد
الليله الماضيه وفي تطور لسلا قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوتها سيطرت على
قريه
القريبه من مدينه باغموت في اقليم دونيتسك
واضافت الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوتها كبدت
القوات الروسيه خسائر ماديه وبشريه كبيره
كما حسنت بعض المناطق
من جانبها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وزير الدفاع سرقه شويغو تفقد مصنعا عسكريا
للغواصات في اقليم بريموري شرقيه البلاد
وقالت الوزاره في بيان لها ان شويغو وجه
بتشغيل المصنع للعمل بكامل طاقته وانجاز
خطط لتحديث الغواصات وتامين كامل لمتطلبات
الاسطول الروسي
وزير الدفاع الروسيه واكد كذلك ان بلاده
تمضي قدما في تعزيز الاسطول الحربي للبلاد
بما يسمح لها بالحفاظ على مصالحها
خلال اجتماعا في مقر الاسطول المحيط
الهادئ الروسي الى ان موسكو عززت اسطولها
خلال الاعوام العشره الماضيه باكثر من 50
سفينه
خلال سنوات العشر الماضيه اعزازنا
الاسطوره البحري الروسي باكثر من 50 سفينه
وهذا العام دخلت الخدمه سفينتان وبحلول
نهايه العام ستدخل الخدمه 12 سفينه اخرى
بينها غواصه صاروخيه واخرى نوويه نعمل على
مشاريع الغواصات النوويه متعدده المهام
والانظمه الاليه والمسيرات تحت المائيه
تحديث اسطولنا يسمح لنا بالحفاظ على
مصالحنا الجيو السياسيه والاستجابه
للتحديات والتهديدات المعاصره
مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه والى
العناوين
بعد سته ايام من فيضانات شرق ليبيا فرق
الاغاثه تكثف البحث عن المفقودين وتواصل
انتشال جثه الضحايا تحذيرات من تلوث
المياه والامم المتحده تقول ان الحجم
الحقيقي للكارثه لا يزال مجهولا والجزيره
ترصد الوضع من داخل درنه وتواكب عمليات
البحث واللغاثه
اسبوع على زلزال الحوس في المغرب عمليات
البحث عن ناجين وانتشالي جتامين الضحايا
تتواصل وسلطات تكثف جهود الاغاثه واياء
المتضررين
والبدايه من تداعيات السيولي في ليبيا
كثره الرجل السالم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
تواصلوا فرق الانقاذ المحليه والاجنبيه في
مدينه درنه الليبيه وباقي المناطق
المتضرره من الاعصار والفيضانات تواصل
جهودها في البحث عن مفقودين واخراج احياء
من وسط الركام رغم صعوبه التحرك في شوارع
المدينه وقد اعلن رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد دبيبه ان فرق البحث
دفنت اكثر من
2500 جثه انتشلتهم من درنه ومع تصاعد
اعداد القتلى والمفقودين ارتفعت وتيره
المنشدات من داخل من داخل درنه والمناطق
الاخرى طلبا لمزيد من الاليات والمعدات
وفرق الانقاذ والخدمات
معنى من طرابلس الان مراسل الجزيره احمد
خليفه
وسيكون معنا بعد قليل من درنه مراسلنا
محمد البقالي سنحاول مع طرابلس مع احمد
خليفه متابعه ما يجري هناك لمعرفه مدى
مواكبه طرابلس لما يجري لكن لنبدا من درنه
ومحمد البقالي اليك محمد
الحقيقه محمد ان ربما الجديد هذا اليوم هو
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقده النائب العام
المنبثق عن مجلس النواب هنا في الشرق
الليبي وايضا رئيس الحكومه ووزير الصحه
والمعطيات الجديده التي تم تقديمها سواء
فيما يتعلق باعداد الضحايا التي قال وزير
الصحه ان الذين تم دفنهم بشكل رسمي قد بلغ
3166 ضحيه هذا يعني ان الارقام ترتفع بما
فيها تلك الارقام الرسميه لان عندما نتحدث
عن الذين تم دفنهم فهذا يعني الذين تاكدت
وفاتهم بشكل كامل هذا دون طبعا
المفقودين ودون الذين تعتقد اسرهم انهم
توفوا دون ان يتم دفنهم والذين لا زالت
جثتهم تحت الالقاب او تلك التي يلقي بها
البحر بشكل مستمر اذن وزير الصحه اكد في
الوقت ذاته ان هذا الرقم هو رقم مؤقت وانه
مرشح للارتفاع ليس فقط مرشح للارتفاع من
المؤكد انه سيرتفع بل ومن المؤكد انه
سيرتفع بشكل كبير بالنظر الى الخراب
والدمار الذي خلفه هذا الفيضان وبالنظر
ايضا الى اعداد المفقودين واعداد الجثث
التي ما تزال تحت الانقاب المساله الاخرى
مهمه ايضا
جاءت هذه المره على لسان النائب العامل
البرلمان الليبي والمتعلقه بمساله فتح
تحقيق في هذه الكارثه هناك الان قناه على
الجميع بان هذه الكارثه كان يمكن تجنبها
او على الاقل كان يمكن تجنب اثارها اثارها
المدمره الذي جعل هذه الكارثه كبيره وبهذا
الحجم هو انفجار الستين انفجار هذين
الستين وتبين ان هذين السدين كان محطه او
محطه تتبع ومراقبه منذ عام 2002 ولحظتها
كان الخبراء يعتقدون ان هناك تشققات وهناك
تصدعات واعطي
دراستهما لبعض الشركات عام 2007 وبعد ذلك
عام 2010 وهناك مسلسل طويل وكله يجمع على
ان هذين السدين لم يكون بالمواصفات
التقنيه والفنيه اللازمه وانه كان يجب
الاشتغال عليهما ولكن لم يتم ذلك ان اذا
عمليا هناك تقصير واضح من قبل الجهات
متعدده وعلى امتداد زمني طويل
النائب العام يتحدث الان على انه سيتم
التحقيق في هذا الامر وقال بان 26 من
النواب المحليين سيتم افادهم الى دارنا من
اجل التحقيق سواء مع المسؤولين المحليين
او مع من هم على مستوى مركزي بغيه تحديد
المسؤوليات وترتيب الجزاءات ثم مساله اخرى
ويبدو انها هذه هي المره في الحقيقه ايضا
مهمه جدا وجاءت على لساني رئيس الحكومه
المعينه من قبل مجلس النواب
يتعلق بمساله العزل تحدث عن امكانيه عزل
بعض الاحياء المتضرره بغيت تجنب المخاطر
الصحيه الكبيره التي تحيط بالمدينه وهذا
الامر في الحقيقه ينسجم مع كل التحذيرات
التي تنطلق من قبل الجهات الصحيه من قبل
الجهات الاغاثيه والتي تحذر من الوضع
الصحي ينذر بالخطر في ظل انتشار الجثث في
ظل المياه التي قد تكون اصبحت غير صالحه
للشرب او في طريقها لذلك عن طريق اختلاط
المياه بالمياه
الصالحه للشرب بالمياه العادمه تداخل مياه
البحر الى اخره كل هذا الوضع خلق وضعا
صحيا ينذر بان المياه لن تكون صالحه او قد
لن تكون صالحه للشرب وهذا
يحق بخطر كبير او ينذر بخطر كبير يحيق
بالمدينه ثم بالاضافه الى الجثث المتحلله
بكل ما يرتبط بها من مخاطر صحيه
هذا الامر كان في البدايه قد دفع اداره
المدينه للحديث عن احتمال اخلاء المدينه
بالكامل ولكن هذا الامر يبدو انه من الصعب
تنفيذه خاصه
حينها سيطرح السؤال اين سيتم ايواء هؤلاء
خاصه وان ثلاثين الفا من الذين هم او من
الذين شردهم هذا الفيضان هم يشكلون في
الحقيقه مشكله كبيره لانهم بالفعل انهم
لجاوا الى معظمهم لجهه الى عائلاتهم خارج
المدينه ولكن في نهايه المطاف يجب ان
يعودوا الى بيوتهم وهذا الامر يطرح اشكالا
كبيرا وبالتالي تم التراجع عن فكره اخلاء
المدينه بشكل كامل ولكن مع ابقاء احتمال
مساله العزل عزل بعض الاحياء بشكل كامل
بغيه تجنب مخاطر صحيه كبيره وهذا الامر في
الحقيقه يعطي اشاره الى حجم الكارثه
الصحيه التي تحق بالمدينه كل هذه المعطيات
التي سميناها هذا اليوم سواء فيما يتعلق
بالجانب الصحي او بجانب الارقام التي لا
او بجانب الاسئله التي اصبحت تطرح الان
بجديه بشان المسؤوليه مسؤوليه
المسؤوليه البشريه فيما حدث لانه الامر لا
يتعلق الان فقط سيول سقطت وجرافه الناس
ولكن يتعلق ايضا بسدود انفجرت وهناك
مسؤوليه لاشخاص في انفجار هذه السدود كل
هذا يعني ان هذا الموضوع مازال مطروحا على
المدى الطويل ربما وسيؤثر على المدى
الطويل سواء على المستوى الانساني على
المستوى الصحي او حتى على مستوى الجنائي
شكرا لك يا محمد البقالي من درنه لنرى
المواضيع المطروحه من العاصمه طرابلس
طرابلس معنا من هناك احمد خليفه احمد
لعل ابرز ما دار في العاصمه طرابلس خلال
مساء هذا اليوم وكما تعلم محمد ان العاصمه
طرابلس هي مركز القرار السياسي
والمالي وبالتالي تتردد فيها اصداء ما
يحدث في درنه بقوه فالحكومه لديها مؤتمر
صحفي كل يوم تعقده هذا المؤتمر يظهر في
عدد من الوزراء ضمن فريق حكومي يسمى فريق
الطوارق هذا الفريق اليوم عقد مؤتمرا
صحفيا على ابرز ما ورد في هذا المؤتمر هو
ان الاعلان ان وزاره الصحه على سبيل
المثال بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه قامت بحصر
الاضرار المتمثله في بندي المعدات
والمستلزمات الطبيه في المناطق المتضرره
وقدرت قيمتها بقرابه 20 مليون دولار ايضا
في سياق اخر وفي سياق الحديث حديث هذا
الفريق الحكومي عن المساعدات الانسانيه
الدوليه والاقليميه التي وصلت الى ليبيا
اذنت هذه الحكومه او اعلنت اللجنه التابعه
لها تحديدا ان اكثر من 30 طائره وصلت من
اكثر من سته عشره دوله الى ليبيا ومن ضمن
هذه المساعدات سفينه تركيه ستصل يوم غد
الى ميناء تبرق ايضا في سياق الاجراءات
الحكوميه والتي تعلن عنها الحكومه استجابه
للاجراءات المتبعه في مدينه درنه اليوم
على سبيل المثال اعلنت الحكومه ان وزيره
شؤونها الاجتماعيه او وزيرتها لشؤون
الاجتماعيه التقت المسؤوله الامميه او
المنسقه الشؤون الانسانيه في البعثه
الاماميه في ليبيا جورجيت غانيون
وناقشت معها تطورات الوضع الانساني في
مدينه درنه
واتفقتا كلتاهما على ان تكون المساعدات
الدوليه بالتنسيق مع الحكومه ايضا في سياق
اخر اعلنت وزاره العدل بحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه اعلنت لاهالي درنه الذين فقدوا
احبتهم في هذه السيول والفيضانات طالبتهم
بالتوجه الى مقرات معينه في مدينه درنه او
الى مواقع معينه
وتقديم حمضهم النووي الى اللجانه التابعه
لهيئه البحث عن المفقودين
لمقارنه هذه العينات بعينات اخرى تؤخذ من
الجثث التي يعثر عليها بين حين واخر في
الاحياء المدمره في مدينه ادرنه ايضا في
سياق الحديث عن اعداد الجثث اليوم لرئيس
الحكومه وعبر منصاته الرسميه المختلفه ان
فريق الرفاه التابع لهيئه البحث عن
المفقودين دفن ما اكثر من 2500 جثه حتى
الان وقال الرئيس الحكومه
قامت بفتح مسارات جديده في مدينه درنه
لتسهيل حركه فرق الانقاذ المحليه
والاقليميه والدوليه وايضا
لتسهيل العثور على الجثث والاحياء
العالقين داخل الاحياء السكنيه وايضا قالت
شركه الخدمات العامه ان الوضع البيئي
يقترب من الكارثه في مدينه درنه ولذلك
قامت بتزويد فرقها هناك مواد متطوره تتعلق
بالتعامل مع المقابر وايضا التعقيم ورش
المبيدات والتعامل مع الوضع الانساني في
المناطق التي توجد فيها جثث الضحايا جراء
هذه
الفيضانات شكرا لك احمد خليفه من طرابلس
نعود مره اخرى الى درنه ولكن هذه المره مع
تامر الصمادي
للاطلاع عن ما جاء في المؤتمر الصحفي
للجنه الطوارئ هناك تامر
بالفعل محمد اهم ما جاء على لسان رئيس
الحكومه المنبثقه عن البرلمان الليبي هو
الشيء المتعلق بعزل المناطق الاكثر تضررا
وهي المناطق التي لا زالت فيها الجثث تحت
الانقاض رقم مرور اليوم السادس على
العاصفه التي خلفت الكثير من الخسائر وهذا
القرار جاء تحسبا تخوفا لوقوع يعني وباء
جديد قد يضرب هذه المدينه في ظل بدء تحلل
الجثث الواقعه تحت الانقاذ هذا ما اشار
اليه
رئيس الحكومه المنبثقه عن البرلمان لكن
كان هنالك ايضا حديثا واضحا للنائب العام
الذي قال وشكك
الاهمال الاهمال الذي وقع نتيجه
انهدام السد
درنا وقال بان ذلك عائد بشكل كبير الى ان
صيانه كانت يجب ان تجرى لهذا السد ولم
تحدث وان هنالك اموالا دفعت في غير مكانها
وقال بان التحقيقات سوف تطال مسؤولين
محليين على راس عملهم في المدينه بالاضافه
الى حكومات متعاقبه لكن في الحقيقه محمد
الوضع في المدينه بعيدا عن المؤتمر الصحفي
هو كارثه وكارثه للغايه منذ الصباح وعد
نحن نتجول في العديد من المناطق التي
اختفت بشكل كبير نتحدث عن طريق طرقات طمست
بالكامل احياء باتت مدمره بشكل كبير
العديد من المباني السكنيه دمرت وجرفت
باتجاه البحر فرق الانقاذ المحليه
والعربيه والاسلاميه والدوليه تبحث حتى
هذه اللحظه عن
المفقودين والحديث عن ارقام تتزايد تتصاعد
بعيدا عن القتله هنالك ايضا الحديث عن
اكثر من الاف مفقود وتم تمن يعني يعطي
ارقاما اعلى من ذلك بكثير في هذه الاثناء
الحديث يتصاعد ايضا عن النازحين خلال
الساعات الماضيه تحدثت السلطات المحليه في
المدينه عن ان عدد النازحين الذين غادروا
المدينه يزيد عن 38 الفا هؤلاء انتقلوا
الى بنغازي بالاضافه الى مدن الشرق
الغرب
وتتحدث ايضا السلطات المحليه عن النازحين
فقدوا منازلهم وفقدوا احبه واهل في هذا
الاحصار وهؤلاء يرفضون الخروج من المدينه
ولذلك تم نقلهم الى العديد من المدارس
والمساجد بالاضافه الى الدوائر الرسميه
والحكوميه في المدينه وتقدم لهم بعض
المستلزمات الحياتيه لكن في الحقيقه وفقا
ونقلا عن المسؤولين الحكوميين ايضا في هذه
المدينه وللمشاهدات هنالك انقطاع كبير في
التيار الكهربائي بالاضافه الى
وشبكات الاتصال والحديث ايضا عن وضع صحي
كارثه لاسيما في المستشفى الحكومي هنا في
المدينه في ظل كما تقول الجهات الصحيه نقص
الامكانيات والمعدات والفرق الطبيه
والكوادر التمريضيه ولذلك هنالك مناشدات
لا تتوقف عن ضروره يعني ارسال مزيد من
المساعدات مزيد من الفرق الاغاثيه لا سيما
بان هذه المدينه قسمت الان الى شطرين
والشطر الاكثر تضررا وفقا للاداره المحليه
في المدينه هو الجانب الشرقي هنالك طرقات
مغلقه بالكامل وهو ما يمنع فرق الانقاذ من
الوصول الى عديد القرى عديد البلدات التي
لا زالت يعني تعيش معاناه صعبه وما زال
ينقل عن الساكنين فيها بان هنالك اناسا
تحت الانقاظ نحن في الحقيقه محمد خلال
جوله هذا اليوم تنقلنا في المناطق المناطق
البحر وعند الشواطئ وكان هنالك يعني جهد
واضح
لانتشال
المفقودين او الغارقين في البحر واعددنا
تقريرا عن ذلك نتابع ابرز ما جاء فيه
اتواجد الان في قلب مدينه درنه للمره
الاولى منذ ان ضربتها العاصفه المدمره
السبت الماضي في هذه الاثناء تعمل فرق
الانقاذ على البحث عن مفقودين
هو جثث واشلاء في هذا البحر في البحر
الابيض
المتوسط عمليات البحث تتواصل في هذا البحر
وعلى شواطئ منذ ايام طويله والحديث عن ان
البحر يلفظ العديد من الجثث في غضون
الساعات الماضيه كما تشاهدون اثار هذه
العاصفه المدمره المزلزله في كل مكان من
هذه الشواطئ يستطيع زميل المصور احمد ان
يقرب لكم صوره هذا الدمار ويعني الوضع
الكارثي الذي بات عليه البحر من كل جهه في
كل منطقه هنالك ركام وبقايا مركبات ومدمره
بطبيعه الحال والبحث يت السلطات المحليه
تتحدث حتى هذه اللحظه وفقا للارقام
الاوليه عن اكثر من خمسه الاف قتيل
والحديث عن اكثر من عشره الاف مفقود يجري
العمل عن البحث عنهم بين الانقاض وبين
الركام وفي الشوارع التي دمرت الى حد كبير
وايضا في عمق هذا البحر تتواصل عمليات
البحث والانقاذ من قبل السلطات وترتفع
وتيره المناشدات ايضا من قبل السلطات
المحليه هنا بارسال بان يقوم العالم
بارسال مزيد من فرق الانقاذ المتخصصه في
مثل هذه الكوارث الكبيره
والمحققه فرق الانقاذ العربيه والدوليه
بدات تصل تباعا لكن المؤمل في الحقيقه هو
ان تكون المساعدات والفرق تتوافد بشكل
اكبر واكبر في ظل ماساه كبيره ولم تكن
متوقعه تامر صمادي الجزيره
معنا من طرابلس الان سيد فتح الله الزوني
وزير الشباب في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
ونائب رئيس الفريق الحكومي للطوارئ
والاستجابه السريعه اهلا وسهلا بك ما
تقييمكم للوضع الان في درنه
مساء الخير
الحقيقه بالنسبه
للاوضاع الميدانيه اليوم في في مدينه درنه
على مستوى فرق العمل الميدانيه من مختلف
الاجهزه يعتبر اليوم
السادس وهي فيه تقدم ملحوظ الحقيقه في
تقديم خدمات
الرعايه الصحيه
والغاثه وايضا على مستوى الفرق انتشار
الجثث
والتعرف على المفقودين اليوم تقريبا كل
الاجهزه تمكنت اليوم الخامس اليوم السادس
كل الاجهزه تمكنت من تحديد نطاق عملياتها
في مدينه درنه بالاضافه الى عدد من القرى
المجاوره لمدينه درنه في منطقه الجبل
الاخضر فيه تحديات على الارض نتيجه هذه
الكارثه
[موسيقى]
اصبحت عديد من الدول التابعه
فرقها في مجال البحث والتعرف على
المفقودين من ناحيه الفنيه
المتخصصه لهذه الفرق جاهزيتها عاليا
تكلموا تقريبا على 16 بعثه من الدول
الصديقه
الشقيقه ارسلت بعثاتها المتخصصه فرقها
المتخصصه في مجال البحث والانقاذ واللقاثه
هي تعمل في منطقه العمليات في درنا ومنطقه
الجبل الاخضر بالنسبه
للتنسيق بين
الشرق والغرب السلطات في الجانبين ما مدى
رضاكم على التجاوب بين الطرفين
في الحقيقه
المعلوم لدى الجميع ان هناك
انقسام
سياسي ما بين الشرق والغرب لكن في مستوى
مواجهه هذه الفاجعه اللي يمروا بها اهلنا
في منطقه جبل لحظه من مدينه درنه الحقيقه
مدينه درنه كما يطلق عليها مدينه الوحده
الوطنيه
كل الجهود اللي تبذل من مؤسسات الرسميه
والاهليه في الشرق وفي الغرب واللي نرصدها
ونتابعها تحت اشراف عمليات الفريق الحكومي
للطوارئ والاستجابه السريعه هناك هناك
مستوى جيد من التنسيق على الارض على مستوى
المناطق اللي تم
فيها جهود عمليات البحث والانقاذ وتقديم
الخدمات الاغاثيه
اليوم ما نتكلموش على المناكفات السياسيه
اليوم نتكلم على الانقسام السياسي كل
الجهود موحده ومسخره بعون الله تعالى
لجبر الضرر
لمواساه ولتقديم الواجب
لاهلنا في منطقه الجبل لاخذروا في مدينه
درنه ما نقدرش نقول انه فيه صعوبات او فيه
تحديات غير قادرين على حلها على مستوى على
المستوى التنسيق بين الشرق والغرب لا
بالعكس هناك تدفق كبير جدا
على مستوى على مستوى
المؤسسات كلها اللي من الغرب الليبي توجهت
للشرقي موجوده اليوم في في مدينه درنه
الجهود
المسانده الجهود التطوعيه الانتقلت من
مختلف مناطق الوطن شرق والغرب وعلمس
والجنوب اللي تتواجد في هذه المناطق تعمل
في نطاق منطقه
تمتثل لتعليمات السلطات المحليه
عدد من الفرق الحكوميه تواجدت في مدينه
درنه وتتواجد رؤساء اجهزه رسميه موجودين
في الشرق الليبي موجودين في مدينه درنه
مدينه سوسه شحات البيضاء يقف على عين
المكان رفقه اللجانهم وفرقهم فرق العمل
متاعهم في في هذه المنطقه من الان لا
نتحدث ولا نقف على اي
انقسام حاصل في السابق قبل هذه الفاجة
وزير الدعوات من جهات مختلفه حول ضروره
فتح تحقيق لتحديد المسؤوليات في مجره هل
تؤيدون ذلك
الحقيقه حكومه الوحده الوطنيه هي اللي
طالبت بفتح تحقيق
وخاطبه السيد المستشار النائب العام
بفتح تحقيق جراء انهيار سد وادي درنه سدين
في درنا سد بو منصور
وادي الضحاك في دارنا السد الكبير والصغير
طلبنا من النائب العام لاجراء التحقيقات
لتحديد المسؤوليات القانونيه امام كل
متورط او من يثبت تورطا في الاهمال
والتقصير وعدم اداء الواجب اتجاه
المدينه والحفاظ على سلامه وجهوزيه
السدين
المرحله الزمنيه الطويله في اداره والحفاظ
على سلامه السد وجهزيته والان الملف منظور
امام النيابه العامه السيد النائب العام
باشر التحقيق في في انهيار السدين ونحن
ننتظر في نتائج التحقيقات
النهائيه في هذا الشام شكرا جزيلا لك فتح
الله جوني وزير الشباب في حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه من طرابلس
هذا وقد قال مدير مركز مكافحه الامراض
للجزيره حيدر السائح ان المياه في مدينه
درنه ملوثه وغير صالحه للشرب مع توقف كامل
لمحطات تحليه المياه واضاف انه يجب اعلان
حاله الطوارئ لمده سنه في كافه المدن
المنكوبه
في الاثناء اعلن المركز الوطني لمكافحه
الامراض في ليبيا عن تسجيل 55 حاله تسمم
بين الاطفال جراء تلوث المياه في درنه
وتوقع حيدر السائح رئيس المركز في حديثا
لوسائل اعلام الليبيه ارتفاع حالات التسمم
في درنه جراء النظام الصحي المتهالك
هذا وتتصاعد تحذيرات من حدوث كارثه صحيه
وبيئيه في المناطق المنكوبه جراء الاعصار
وعلى وجه الخصوص مدينه درنه اذ يحذر خبراء
البيئه من انتشار الامراض المعديه
والاوبئه نتيجه تلوث مياه الشرب في
المدينه
درن المنكوبه وجه اخر يتكشف عن مدينه
منهكه لم تكن السيول سوى ضربه قاسمه لها
تتعمق الماساه الانسانيه في درنا بحديث
خبراء البيئه عن هواجس من تفشي الاوبئه
والامراض المعديه بسبب تدمير شبكات الصرف
الصحي والنفايات التي تحملها مياه السيول
يتحدث تقرير للامم المتحده عن خطر انتشار
امراض مثل السل والحصبه والانفلونزا في
المناطق المنكوبه شرقيه ليبيا فالنفايات
التي تحملها مياه السيول تحتوي مواد ضاره
ما سيؤدي الى تلوث مياه الشرب والابار
وبالتالي نشر الامراض والاوبئه المركز
الوطني لمكافحه الامراض في ليبيا اعلن
تسجيل 55 حاله تسمم بين الاطفال جراء تلوث
المياه في درنه حذر المركز من ارتفاع
حالات التسمم فالنظام الصحي هناك متهالك
ويطالب باخلاء كامل المدينه نحو 300 الف
انسان كانوا يعيشون في درنه قبل الكارثه
لسنوات عان هؤلاء من تهاون منظومه الصحيه
فدرنا ثالث اكبر مدينه في الشرق الليبي
لكنها تضم ثلاثه مرافق صحيه حكوميه فقط هي
مستشفى الوحده التعليميه الجامعي ومستشفى
الهريش وهو مجمع عيادات حكومي ومستوصف
شيحه عام 2019 خرج مستشفى الهريش عن
الخدمه وظل متوقفا عن العمل حتى يومنا هذا
اما مستشفى الوحده وهو على الرغم من انه
المستشفى المركزي والاكبر في درنه فقد كان
يعمل قبل الكارثه بعشره في المئه فقط من
طاقته ليبقى مستوصف شيحه المرفق الصحي
الحكوميه الوحيد الذي لم يتوقف عن العمل
ولكنه ذو طاقه محدوده وامكانيات متواضعه
جدا عانى افتقارا في الكوادر الطبيه اذ لم
يتجاوز عدد الاطباء فيها الثمانيه
بالاضافه الى سبعه مساعدين ومن صور حول
الكارثه شكوى هل الضحايا من شح الاكياس
الخاصه بالجثث بل ان ثلاجات الموتى رغم
تكدس الجثث داخلها متوقفه عن العمل
لانقطاع الكهرباء عن المدينه وقد اضطرت
فرق الطوارئ في درنا الى نقل الجثث على
متن شاحنات الى مستشفى طبرق الى حين
التعرف عليها ودفنها
[موسيقى]
معنى من طرابلس الدكتور بدر النجار المدير
العام السابق للمركز الوطني لمكافحه
الامراض في ليبيا اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور هذه
الاحاديث عن مخاوف من انتشار اوبئه او غير
ذلك في درنه ما مدى صدقيه ذلك
هو الحقيقه بدايه اعزي نفسي واعزي اهل
درنا وكل ليبيا بمن توفوا وقضوا في هذه
الكارثه الكبيره الحقيقه في كارثه زي هديه
صراحه تصير فيه فوضى في النظام البيئي
وتختلط مياه الصرف الصحي بمياه شرب ولو
تبقى الناس وتشرب المياه اللي موجود هذه
بالتاكيد تكون ملوثه بانواع مختلفه من
البكتيريا وربما فيروسات وسيرا انفجار
وبائي في على هيئه الاسهالات وخاصه في
اكثر الفئه عرضه اللي هم الاطفال فهذا
علاج وصه المركز الوطني باخلاء المنطقه
المنكوبه على الاقل المنطقه المنكوبه يتم
اخلاهم ووضعهم في ملاجئ مؤقته ليتم ترميم
شبكات الصرف الصحي ويتم التاكد من
مياه الشرب من الملوثات
فما حدث الان شفت انت التقرير اللي طلع
المركز الوطني يعني هذا بدايه 55 طفل
ومتوقع يكون اكثر واحنا نتمنوا انه ما
يصيرش انفجار وبائي وتتوسع
عدد الحالات في الاصابات الاسهال او غيرها
من الاصابات اصابات الجهاز التنفسي وتصبح
نهايه وباء وتشكل مشكله صحيه فيجب بعد
الفرق الاغاثه او فرق الطوارئ اللي موجوده
غادي اخذ الحذر واخلاء المنطقه المنكوبه
ضروري من اخلاقها ووضعهم في ملاجه وحتى في
المناجي يعني لابد من توفير الرعايه
الصحيه المطلوبه سواء كان للاطفال يعني 55
هدف في وجود فرق المركز الوطني المتخصصه
لكي بالامكان التعامل معهم اعطاهم الادويه
وايقاف هذا يعني الاصابات اللي نتجت عن
طريق الماء ولكن يجب توفير المياه النظيفه
للناجين وايضا السكاني لمزاله موجودين يتم
اخلاقهم لملاجئ بحيث يتم تقديم الرعايه
الصحيه لهم ومش فقط الاطفال يعني عنا حتى
الناس الكبار في السنه واللي عندهم امراض
مزمنه لابد من الاهتمام بهم وتوفير ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكر وادويه القلب وكل
الامراض المزمنه الثانيه لان في من امراض
يتوقف المريض عن ياخذ الدواء يوم الاثنين
قد تتفاقم حاله الصحيه ممكن تؤدي حتى الى
التعقيدات صحيه خطيره ممكن تؤدي حتى الى
الوفاه يعني هذا الدكتور هذا الاخلاء الذي
تشير اليه
ما الذي يميزه عن ما يطرح حاليا من ضروره
عزل بعض المناطق حتى لا تتفشى امراض بين
بين المناطق المختلفه
لا هو الحقيقه ما يشاع من ان الجثث ممكن
هي التي تحدث وباء في اغلب الاحوال والراي
العلمي الجثث
ما تتسببش في نشر الاوبئه ربما في قليل من
الاحداث زي مثلا الجثث المصابه
بفيروس كورونا ممكن تقعد
تتسبب في العدوى لبعض الوقت اسابيع ولكن
عادى ذلك الجثث علميا لا تتسبب في نشر
الاوبئه ولكن ما ينشر الاوبئه هو التلوث
وجود الناس اقتضاض الناس في الملاجئ ربما
تنتشر بيناتهم يعني بعض امراض التهاب
الجهاز التنفسي الفيروسيه والانفلونزا
ربما في تلوث المياه هديه لو تبقى الناس
في الاماكن المنكوبه وفي تلوث مياه الشرب
وتستمر في شرب المياه فقدر الله ربما
ينتشر مرض الكوليرا وهذا مرض خطير يعني
ممكن يؤدي بحياه الاطفال حتى للوفاء
فالحقيقه الناجي الان لو يتم اخلاها ووضح
في ملاجه يسهل التعامل معها ويسهل حفظ
صحتها وتقديم حتى مش الرعايه الصحيه بس
محتاجين حتى للدعم الصحي
للدعم النفسي والدعم الاجتماعي ناس يعني
اكيد متاثرين بعد الصدمه فمحتاجين
للعنايه الصحيه والعنايه النفسيه وايضا
يعني حتى نتمنى وزاره شؤون جمعيه تهتم بكل
تاكيد في اطفال ايتام ومصدومين ويبوا
عنايه خاصه من الناس متخصصه
فالاخلاق هذا نشوف فيه امر ضروري ولكن
يقتصر عليه الاماكن او المناطق شكرا واللي
النظام الصحي والبيئي يعني حدث فيها خلل
كبير شكرا
المدير العام السابق للمركز الوطني
لمكافحه الامراض شكرا لك
قال نائب رئيس المجلس المحلي في مدينه
درنه احمد مدبر الجزيره ان هناك توقعات
بامكانيه اخلاء المدينه بشكل كلي او جزئي
تحسبا لانتشار الاوبئه نتيجه الجثث التي
بدات في التحلل تحت الانقاد وتوقع مدور
اخلاء حي الجبيله وحي المغار وما تبقى من
سكان وسط المدينه التي تعرضت للدمار مضيفا
ان هناك دراسه تجري لتقييم الوضع مؤكدا
نزوح اعداد كبيره من سكان الاحياء
المنكوبه
هذا وقد حصلت شبكه الجزيره على مشاهد
حصريه تظهر انتشال جثث لضحايا الفيضانات
من البحر في مدينه درنه وتظهر المشاهد جثه
قذفها البحر الى شاطئ المدينه وبدا فرق
الانقاذ عمليه انتشالهم هذا وتتواصل جهود
البحث من قبل فرق انقاذ الليبيه واجنبيه
املا في العثور على جثث ضحايا قذفت بهم او
قذفت بهم السيول عفوا الى البحر قباله
شواطئ درنه
في الاثناء قال احمد المسماري المتحدث
باسم الجيش في بنغازي ان الاعصار الذي ضرب
منطقه الجبل الاخضر هو الاسوا الذي تشهده
ليبيا وانه جرف كل شيء امامه مشيرا الى
تاثر اكثر من مليون شخص بالسيول
يعني نتحدث من ناحيه الوراث السكان على
حوالي اكثر من مليون و 200 الف نسمه
يقتلون في هذه المناطق وهذه المنطقه مقتله
بالسكان هذه المنطقه فيها خمس مدن رئيسيه
وهي مدينه المرج بعد ذلك مدينه البيضه بعد
ذلك ساحات سوسه القبه هذه المنطقه
هذا الوصف السكاني والوصف الخريطه
الطبيعيه لهذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه ضربت
بالكامل هذا الاحصار عندما دخل من من
اتجاه الغرب الى الشرق يقوم بمسح كل شيء
امانه
[موسيقى]
الان الى المغرب والمشهد بعد مرور اسبوع
على الزلزال
[موسيقى]
تتواصلوا عمليات البحث عن ناجين وانتشال
جتامين الضحايا في غضون ذلك تستمر عمليته
فتح الطرق الجبليه المؤديه الى القرى
النائيه وسط مخاوفه من انهيارات صخريه
جديده وكانت وزاره الداخليه المغربيه قد
افادت بارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى
2946 والمصابين الى خمسه الاف وستمائه
واربعه وسبعين وكانت السلطات المغربيه قد
اعلنت بدات تنفيذ المرحله الاولى من خطه
طارئه لاوائي متضرري زلزل
ينضم الينا الان من مراكش مراسل الجزيره
عمر الحاجه اهلا بك عمر كيف هي المدينه
هذا المساء
نعم محمد بالنسبه لسكان المدينه فالكثير
ممن اعتاد ان يقضي ليلته في الخارج وضبا
على هذا هذا السلوك فتركنا وسط المدينه
اضافه الى الكثير من الاحياء خاصه القريبه
من المدينه القديمه
متجمعين هناك في خيام بسيطه اعدوها على
عجل بجهود ذاتيه اما الامر بالنسبه
للمناطق التي زرناها اليوم في جولاتنا
صباحا سواء في الحوزه وحتى في شيشاوه
الامر لا يختلف كثيرا ولكن الفرق ان
السلطات هي التي تقدم الخيم
لهؤلاء العمل الان اكثر تنظيما فيما يخص
موضوع الاغاثه بالتحديد بعد ان هامت
السلطات بكل المواطنين الذين ياتون من
مختلف المناطق للتبرع بالمساعدات العينيه
بايداعها في مستودعات خاصه اعادتها ومخازن
خاصه عدتها حتى يتم توزيعها ليس فقط
بشكل منظم ولكن بالتساوي على الضحايا
والمنكوبين خاصه اذا ما اشرنا الى ان وفق
لشهادات الاهالي ايضا في شيشاوه ان
المساعدات تصل بوتيره اقل بكثير مما يحدث
لمساعدات المتوجهه الى الحوز وايضا
بدا العمل
باجراء القوائم قوائم الاحصاء للعوائل
التي ستستفيدوا من المنحه التي قدمتها او
المساعده العاجله تقدمها الحكومه 3000
دولار للاسر المتضرره توزع لمره والتنمره
واحده اضافه الى
مساعدات تصل الى 13 الف دولار بالنسبه
للاشخاص الذين فقدوا بيوتهم بشكل كامل
اخيرا محمد الارصاد الجويه في المملكه
تحدثت عن طقس حار في الايام المقبله ولكن
هذا لما لم يخوف لم يهدئ من مخاوف
المواطنين خاصه في
المنكوبه المنتشره في الجبال من
وجوه او تساقط الامطار كما هو المعتاد
وبالتالي ستصبح مهمه ايواءهم اصعب وستكون
الظروف الجويه قاسيه جدا بشكل لا يستطيعون
تحمله وعلى ذلك بالرغم من تفهمهم بصعوبه
الموقف الان ولكنه يطالبون بمزيد والاسراع
بالمزيد في خاصه فيما يتعلق
الملاجئ او حتى المساكن المؤقته لتقياهم
على الاقل في الفتره المقبله ريثما يتم
تجهيز بيوت ليعودوا اليها مره اخرى
شكرا جزيلا لك عمر الحاج من مراكش
معنى الان من الرباط عبد اللطيف وهبي وزير
العد المغربي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد الوزير ما
تقييم كل الوضع الان بعد اسبوع على
الزلزال
كل مساء الخير شكرا على اهتمامكم بهذه
النزيله
والوضع الان مازال مازال نحن مستمرين في
قضيه البحث عن العالقين مده التي مرت
لانها لا نريد ان نترك احدا وراءنا ثم تم
دفن الجثه تعتقد النبقه الجثتين
اليوم دفنت اليوم وبذلك فاننا نحاول ان
ننهي هذه المرحله الاولى ثم انتقلنا اليوم
الى المرحله الثانيه بعد الاجتماع الذي
تراسه جهه الملك وحدد مجموعه من المعايير
ومجموعه من الوسائل العمل من اجل ايواء
المتضررين
بوضعيتهم ثم التعويضات التي ستقدمها اليوم
التي حددت وكذلك فتح الصندوق رقم الحساب
رقم 126 الذي
تم ايداع فيه جميع
المبالغ التي تم تقديمها من طرف المواطنين
والمؤسسات والشركات الخاصه غير ذلك او
الموظفين غير ذلك من اجل المساهمه في
اعاده بناء واعمار هذه المناطق واسكانيه
هذه التعويضات سيد الوزير هل هل هي تعويض
نهائي عن البيت بمعنى لن يتم تعويض الناس
ببيوت اخرى
نحن اولا لهم الخيار لانه غالبا هؤلاء
الناس يتمسكون بمواقعهم التي كانوا فيها
نحن سنقدم لهم جميع الوسائل التقنيه وجميع
الوسائل العلميه حتى التصاميم حتى نسهل
عمل العمل التقني اضافه الى ذلك هناك قرار
من نسميها نحن المحافظه العقاريه تسمى
التسجيل التي ستتبع الموضوع وسيتم
مساعدتهم الى حين اعمار البيوت
اخرى سنقررها في حينها
هل من الممكن الاسراع بذلك قبل دخول فصل
الشتاء وتلك المناطق شديده البروده
القرار اتحد البارح بالامس بعدما تاكدنا
حول وضعيه العالقين وضعيه اللغه وبعد
الاجتماع والحكومه برئاسه السيد رئيس
الحكومه اجتمعنا وحددنا برنامج عمل لنبدا
فورا للقيام بهذا العمل وفيه شقين الشق
الاول تهيئ اعاده الاعمار والشقه الثاني
وايواء هؤلاء الاشخاص وتمكين من الوسائل
يتقدمنا دولار حتى نساعدهم في اللواء
المؤقت ثم كذلك مكانه من الصيام ومن
الافرشه وحدد بعض الاماكن لان بعض الاماكن
كحلات الرياضيه ذلك وبعض القاعات الرياضه
من اجل صقرها في انتظار ان انه يتم اتمام
المشروع ونحن بدانا بدانا اليوم وهو وزيره
السكنه وزيره السكنه سيدي فاطمه الزهراء
المنصوري هي اكبر برنامجا وتصورا ونحن ان
شاء الله تنفيذه للتوجيهات الملك سنجم هدف
اقرب وقت في اسرع وقت ما مدى رضاكم حول
المساعدات التي وصلتكم من الخارج الى حد
الان
نحن تقررنا ما هي المساعده
بناء الحاجات الحاجيات التي نحتاجها وبناء
على ما نعتقد انه صحيح لذلك سيكون رضانا
بناء على اختياراتنا ستكون على اختياراتنا
نحن كان هناك تعلمون جيدا سيد الوزير كان
هناك نوع من الجدل حول الدول المسموح لها
او غير المسموح لها كما قيل هل ننتظر في
فتره مقبله ان تتسع قائمه الدول التي ترغب
المملكه في ان تصل مساعدات منها
ليست هناك دول
قبلناها هناك اولويات وهناك متطلبات طبيعه
الاولويات والمتطلبات التي حدثت الدول
التي تعاملنا اليها في الاول كنا محتاجين
الى الوسائل لاخراج العالقين والى الكلاب
التي لا هذا التمرس والى
سيساعدونا في ايجاد العالقين الان اعلنا
انه هناك صندوق لدعم هؤلاء في كل من اراد
ان يساهم في هذا الصندوق فليساهم فيه يعني
هذه المساهمات يعني ممكن مقصود منها
مساهمه الداخليه ام تقصدون حتى مساهمات من
الخارج
هي اساسا مساهمه الداخليه سوف تطرق لها
حينما تاتي سنتطرق اليها نحن نسير خطوطا
بخطوه
بشكل منظم نحن دوله في اخر المطاف
واعاده البناء سنرى ما احتياجاتنا وسنقرر
اقبلها شكرا جزيلا لك وزير العدل المغربي
عبد اللطيف الوهبي من الرباط
شكرا يمر سكان القرى المتضرره من الزلزال
في اقليم تارودانت بالمغرب باوضاع صعبه
بعد زلزال الحوز الذي ضرب المنطقه الجمعه
الماضي ويامل سكان هذه القرى ان تسهم
السلطاته في رفع العزله عن قراهم والاسراع
في اعاده ترميم المدارس وتوفير فرص العمل
الى مكان الفاجعه في الركام يبحث عبد
الحفيظ عما تبقى من وثائقه الشخصيه
لا اله الا الله لا اله الا الله ويتحسر
على فقدان والده الذي تعذر عليه انقاذه
ليله الزلزال
شانه في ذلك شان مجموعه من الناجين
المجبرين على العمل في مناطق بعيده عن
قراهم
ما كايناش كيشربوا
[تصفيق]
لا فرص عمل هنا يقول سكان المناطق
المنكوبه فزراعه لا تكفي لتامين الحياه
الكريمه لكنهم رغم ذلك
يتشبثون بالمكوث في قرن شيدها اجدادهم حتى
ان كان ذلك مرادفا لعزله تفرضها طرق وعره
يستنزف سلوك دروبها نصف ساعات النهار
تقريبا تنمشي اربعه د المرات في النهار
تنمشي تنطلع ديال الطريق وتايخصني نرجع
عاوتاني نص ساعه ديال الطريق وتنمشي عده
مرات في النهار اربعه مرات خمسه مرات في
النهار
ولان النوائب لا تاتي فرادى يخشى
المنكوبون ان يطول عدم التحاق اطفالهم
بالمدارس
فالمؤسسات التعليميه التي تؤوي اطفال
القرى القصيه لم تسلم بدورها من عنف
الزلزال
لذلك تحاول الجمعيات المحليه ايجاد حلول
مؤقته لاطفال لم يستسلموا لقسوه اوضاع ما
بعد الزلزال نحن كجمعيه شباب
الدوار تمثلت نفكر حاليا واتصلنا بمجموعه
من الجمعيات الفعاله في مدن اخرى باش توفر
لنا الحاويات من اجل ترصيه مدارس مؤقته
ويستافدوا منها مجموعه من الدوائر الاخرى
لا يملك ضحايا زلزال الحوز الا التاقلم مع
واقع جديد لا يقل قسوه عن واقعهم الذي
كانوا فيه لكنهم يخشون ان يتحول هذا الوضع
المؤقت الى وضع دائم وان يزيدهم عزله بعد
عزله ايمن زوبير الجزيره من قريه تيزنتاس
في شمال اقليم تارودانت
في اخبارنا الاخرى رحب مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي بزياره وفد حوثي للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه داعيا جميع الاطراف الى
زياده تعزيز فوائد الهدنه في اليمن
زياره وفد من الحوثيين الى السعوديه هي
خطوه كبيره تحدث لاول مره منذ فتره طويله
فهي تاتي في لحظه بعد مرور 18 شهرا من
الهدنه التي وضعت حدا للعنف الذي حل
باليمن في السنوات الماضيه نحن نحيي حكومه
عمان على جهودها المتواصله في هذا الاطار
ونحن نعمل عن قرب مع الاطراف اليمنيه
والامم المتحده نحن نحيي القياده السعوديه
ايضا وهي تعمل على انهاء الصراع في اليمن
ونعتقد ان ذلك سيعود بالنفع على الجميع
سلمت الكويت مذكره احتجاج لسفير العراق
لديها على خلفيه حكم المحكمه العليا
الدستوريه في العراق القاضي بعدم دستوريه
اتفاقيه تنظيم الملاحه البحريه بين
البلدين في خور عبد الله وقال بيان
للخارجيه الكويتيه ان مساعده وزير
الخارجيه سلم السفير العراقي مذكره احتجاج
على ما تم ذكره في حيثيات الحكم حول
الاتفاقيه المبرمه بين البلدين بشان تنظيم
الملاحه البحريه في خور عبد الله
سوداني ان سته اشخاص لقوا مصرعهم بسبب
سيول وامطار ضربت عده مناطق في ولايه نهر
النيل شمالي البلاد وقالت مصادر محليه
للجزيره الى مئات المنازل انهارت بسبب
سيول وامطار ضربت ثلاث بلدات بمحليه بربر
في ولايه نهر النيل شماليه السودان واكدت
المصادر ان اكثر من 350 منزلا انهارت بشكل
كامل في قريه سينما جنوبي بربر اضافه الى
انهيار منازل اخرى لم يتم حصرها في كل من
قريتي اسعد الساعه السعدبيه والنبويه وزار
والي الولايه القرى المتضرره اليوم داعيا
المنظمات الانسانيه لتقديم يد العون
للمتضررين
قالت مندوبه الولايات المتحده الدائمه لدى
الامم المتحده ليندا توماس غريفيلد ان
تهديد القاده العسكريين في السودان بانهاء
مهمه الامم المتحده في البلاد امر غير
مقبول واضافت في لقاء مع مجله الامريكيه
ان هذا التهديد مودان وعلى قاده العسكري
سحبه على الفور حسب تعبيرها
هذا التهديد غير مقبول على الاطلاق وعلينا
ان ندينهم عليه تقدم بعثه الامم المتحده
هناك الدعم للشعب السوداني وهذه البعثه
مهمه لضمان استمرارنا في دعم الشعب
السوداني والوقوف الى جانبه لذا فانني
احثهم على ان يسحبوا هذا التهديد وان
يبحثوا عن طريقه للعمل مع الامم المتحده
لفتح الممرات الانسانيه لكي تتمكن
المساعدات الانسانيه من المرور وان يمنحوا
التاشيرات للعاملين في المجال الانساني
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها
دمرت سبعه عشر طائره مسيره روسيه من طراز
شاهد الليله الماضيه وفي تطور ذي صله قالت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوتها سيطرت
على قريه
القريبه من مدينه في اقليم دونيتسك واضافت
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوتها كبدت القوات
الروسيه خسائر ماديه وبشريه كبيره كما
حسنت بعض المناطق
من جانبها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويغو تفقد مصنعا
عسكريا للغواصات في اقليم برومري شرقي
البلاد وقالت الوزاره في بيان لها
النشويجو وجه بتشغيل المصنع للعمل بكامل
طاقته وانجاز خطه لتحديث الغواصات وتامين
كاملا لمتطلبات الاسطول الروسي
وزير الدفاع الروسيه اكد كذلك ان بلاده
تمضي قدما في تعزيز الاسطول الحربي الروسي
بما يسمح لها بالحفاظ على مصالحها الجيو
السياسيه واشار شويغو خلال اجتماعا في مقر
الاسطول المحيط الهادئ الروسي الى ان
بلاده عززت اسطولها خلال الاعوام العشره
الماضيه باكثر من 50 سفينه
خلال سنوات العشر الماضيه اعزازنا
الاسطوره البحري الروسي باكثر من 50 سفينه
وهذا العام دخلت الخدمه سفنتان وبحلول
نهايه العام ستدخل الخدمه 12 سفينه اخرى
بينها غواصه صاروخيه واخرى نوويه نعمل على
مشاريع الغواصات النوويه متعدده المهام
والانظمه الاليه والمسيره تحت المائيه
تحديث اسطولنا يسمح لنا بالحفاظ على
مصالحنا الجيو السياسيه والاستجابه
للتحديات والتهديدات المعاصره
افرجت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه اليوم
عن الاسير خليل عواوده من حاجز الجيب
العسكري شمال غربيه القدس المحتله بعد
اعتقال دام اثنين وعشرين شهرا واكد الاسير
عوده للجزيره على وحده الحركه الاسيره
داخل المعتقلات وانها افشلت مخططات وزير
الامن القوميه الاسرائيلي يتمر بن كثير
الرميه لكسر اراده الاسرى واتخاذ خطوات
انتقاميه بحقهم وكان الاسير عواوده وهو من
سكان بلده قريبه من الخليل والبالغ من
العمر واحد واحد واربعين عاما قد اعتقل في
نهايه شهر ديسمبر كانون الاول من عام 2021
تراجعت شرطه الاسرائيليه عن ادعاءاتها
بضبط متفجرات داخل السياره التي اعترضتها
في شارع رئيسي قرب مدينه الرمله جنوب تل
ابيب واعتقلت ركابها الثلاثه ولكنها اكدت
مع ذلك الاشتباه بوجود علاقه بين ركاب هذه
السياره والعبوه الناسفه التي انفجرت صباح
اليوم في منتزه الياركون العوجه في تل
ابيب
وذكرت الشرطه ان جهاز الامن العام الشباك
يشارك في التحقيقات بشان ملابسات وخلفيات
الحادثين والاشتباه بانه امني ولم يخلف
الانفجار اضرارا او اصابات وياتي هذا
التطور عشيه عيد راس السنه العبريه حيث
رفعت سلطات الامن الاسرائيليه من درجه
تاهبها ونشرت تعزيزات امنيه في الميادين
الرئيسيه داخل المدن وتحديدا في القدس
المحتله
والان القراءه لابرز ما تناولته الصحف
والمواقع الاخباريه بشان الفيضانات في
ليبيا والزلزال في المغرب نتابعه في
التقرير التالي
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز كتبت حول تحد كبير
يواجهه عمال الاغاثه في اكثر المناطق
تضررا من الفيضانات في درن الليبيه اذ
اصبح انتشار الجثث ثم دفنها اكثر صعوبه
الصحيفه نقلت عن احدهم قوله ان مئات الجثث
تدفن في مقابر جمعيه بسبب كثره ضحايا
الكارثه وضروره الاسراع لانتشار المزيد من
الجثث قبل تحللها تناولت صحيفه الجارديان
قرار منع مدنيين من دخول المنطقه المدمره
في مدينه درنه وقالت انها محاوله لافساح
المجال لعمال الاغاثه وسط ارتفاع كبير في
عدد ضحايا الكارثه ومخاوف من اخطار بيئيه
محتمله ونبهت الصحيفه الى تصريح لرئيس
وحده الطب الشرعي باللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر يحذر من ان الناجين من كارثه
طبيعيه قادرون على نشر الامراض اكثر من
الجثث
الفرنسيه اشارت الى ان الوصول الى المنطقه
المتضرره من الفيضانات في ليبيا لا يزال
صعبا بسبب الدمار الذي لحق بالطرقات
والجسور المؤديه اليها بالاضافه لانقطاعات
الكهرباء وشبكه الهاتف وذكرت الصحيفه ان
ما لا يقل عن 30 الف شخص اصبحوا بلا ماوى
قال موقع 360 المغربي ان الصندوق المستحدث
لمواجهه تداعيات الزلزال حقق ارقاما تعكس
هبه تضامنيه تشبه تلك التي سادت خلال
الازمه الصحيه التي سببها فيروس كورونا
وذكر الموقع ان قيمه التبرعات المعلنه
تجاوزت عتبه خمسه مليارات درهم دون احتساب
التبرعات الفرديه والعينيه الموجهه مباشره
لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال صحيفه الاخبار
المغربيه سلطت الضوء على الجهود التي
تبدلها بعض الجمعيات الناشطه في مجال
الرعايه النفسيه بالمغرب للتكفل بضحايا
الزلزال ونقلت عن اذه متخصصه في الطب
النفسي والعقلي بكليه الرباط القول ان
المرافقه النفسيه جزء مهم من الدعم اللازم
للمتضررين من زلزال الحوز خصوصا الاطفال